El grupo político asamblea majorera,
coalición Canaria,
celebró 1 rueda de prensa este lunes22 de abril,
para mostrar su rechazo ante la minería
de tierras raras
e informar de que llevará
al próximo pleno del Parlamento de Canarias
1 proposición no de ley
que se presentará como enmienda de sustitución
a la propuesta
por nueva Canarias.
Esto supone que el texto que se votará
serán los 8 puntos
elaborados por Cece
y Pepe, esenciales
para acabar con la especulación
de la minería de tierras
raras en Fuerteventura.
El secretario insular,
Mario Cabrera,
insistió en la importancia
de apoyar este texto por unanimidad
y tener en cuenta que supone 1 mandato
directo al gobierno de Canarias,
ya que la realizan los partidos que apoyan al ejecutivo
autonómico. Presentamos
1 proposición no de ley en el Parlamento
que recoge los 4 puntos
aprobados en las distintas instituciones,
que ha ratificado la fecan, que ratifica la fecay,
y que ampliamos en lo que es el sentir generalizado
de lo que está pasando en Canarias,
porque queremos que esto
no solo sea el tema de las tierras raras
en Fuerteventura,
sino entendemos que en Canarias tampoco,
pero 2 puntos nuevos
que es instar al gobierno de España
eh instar al gobierno canario
para qué instar al gobierno de España,
modificar 1 ley que es del 73,
que es la de Mina, que es la que nos pone en riesgo,
y avanzar en la elaboración de decreto
para cualquier tipo de extracciones
de los que No están regulados
donde se consulte previamente
1 demanda
clave a los ayuntamientos o cabildos afectados,
es decir,
que Sean vinculantes ese tipo de informes previos.
Además, Cabrera incidió en que la propuesta
presentada por nueva Canarias
es incompleta
por no responder a las peticiones
de las instituciones de la Isla,
además de contradictoria